okay so here we are this is eating your
feed my name is Nikki this is Andrew our
friends Adam and Annie challenged us to
recreate some of the most viral foods on
the Internet today we are making
mozzarella
today we're watching a tasty video
called how mozzarella is made which is
about a place in New York City called
Casa della mozzarella so they have a big
block of mozzarella curd a guitar that's
just a way to cut it up heat up curds
with hot water and you add salt and you
kind of squidge it together that's the
cheese pull you want and they make it
into this little like ball shape this is
the process of mozzarella curd tomate
Sorella so we're gonna have to make our
own mozzarella curd for sure we need to
start from a mill a milk product this is
a mozzarella recipe on Epicurious and it
does call for liquid rennet what is Rena
curdled milk from the stomach of an
unweaned calf oh so hopefully we can get
that at Whole Foods like always our good
friend and tasty producer / chef RIA is
here do you know anything about how to
make mozzarella great meaning there
basically it's milk
rennet citric acid and salt you don't
like mix all of this together you heat
it up you stir it and then you set it
aside and it becomes curds yes and then
we're gonna eat it after we make it so
is there anything you'd like to eat with
some fresh mozzarella pizza yes I think
it's not that difficult all right we got
ah run it tablets citric acid 1/4 TSP
liquid rennet told us not to use junket
but that's what that is
you're good at this silverlight cheesed
or what does they don't have liquid
running hi I know you're a cheese store
but I'm looking to make my own cheese
and uh I'm looking for this thing called
a rennet preferably the liquid rennet
okay thank you take care now
I do not love him yeah this cheese store
has liquid rennet so we're in luck
liquid vegetable rennet now let's get
out of here got cheese to me
please don't take this this Rena is
double strength use a third of what
recipe calls for so we're starting with
one gallon of milk we will need a wealth
of a teaspoon how about like three drops
I think it's preposterous that's it
that's like not even gonna make it into
the bowl a quarter cup of water for a
quarter teaspoon of liquid Rena I think
I'd rather overdo it
you'd rather have to cheese cheese then
no no no no no all right there seems
preposterous like that few drops of a
thing that that was important that's
what we drove all over town for a couple
drip-drop get your gas and a cup of
water
mozzarella comes from the heart not the
brain but it comes from the udder should
we drink a little mm-hmm one gallon of
whole milk add the citric acid mixture
heat to a medium-high heat until it
reaches 90 degrees oh it's curdling 91
we drop counts okay it's been 30 seconds
all right just give it another 15
seconds cover and set aside for 5
minutes bye oh whoa yeah it says a
gelatin like consistency would you say
that the gelatin like I would say this
is pretty gelatinous set the pot over
medium heat we're gonna stir
intermittently without breaking up the
curds that we just cut give it to Jeff
first we're gonna be reaching a
temperature of 105 degrees whoa some
curds are hotter than others some cards
are hotter than others
yeah okay I'm turning off the heat here
it comes oh it's already kind of cheesy
oh no wait we were supposed to set it
aside for another 5 minutes 5 minutes
here into the strainer discard the way
clump the curds it looks like cheese
we're straining out as much of the
liquid as possible so this is the
leftover liquid is called whey needs
salt oh yeah that's Kirti for a bouncy
Oh
look like gross pantyhose we've made our
own mozzarella curd and now we're
basically going to season it with salt
gently melt it with some hot water until
it becomes elastic and kind of comes
together as a single lobular cheese yeah
[Music]
the pedal is too big for this bowl can
you overwork it is there such thing do
we have to like dump out this water and
get pot or water in there yeah we've
definitely made progress but I think
we've kind of lost it on this step here
it's kind of like stuffing it under and
then squeezing it so it erupts from the
top of his hand well I got some good
daddy's mozzarella mozzarella let's cut
it
that is mozzarella that looks like
cheese yeah this is mozzarella I don't
know what mozzarella tastes like right
now all the right texture no this is way
too light we shouldn't be able to split
it open like this this looks like a
vagina do you feel discouraged I may
have added too much Renan rennet so I
think we also overworked the curds
okay now let's heat it over top record
the last time when we did this I just
like ripped it apart with my hands so
we're gonna do instead I let them dry
out and then cut it into Kurt's we don't
have a guitar but we cut it up into
pieces and this is when we add the salt
which we should use more than we used
last time now we're adding the boiling
water and hopes of melting the cheese
together does it feel different than I
did last time yeah it feels softer
overall tug it down so I kind of stretch
out all of the what might be inside of
it you know yeah we should keep it in
one mess though cuz if we have too many
strings and we fold it over on itself
and it's just a bulb strings okay we're
gonna set our finished mozzarella balls
in a little basin of ice water nice oh
yeah that looks really good those are
like the folds but they
definitely not as big as previously I'd
say it's still pretty rubbery just
doesn't have like that rich dairy taste
[Music]
we asked Korea doesn't have flavor so
here we are on day 2 of eating your
cheese after watching a bunch of videos
I think we've realized that the recipe
we were referencing it's designed to
make cheese as fast as possible so
overall we're gonna be taking more time
on each step today we're also using raw
milk today so we'll pretty much we're
doing the same thing just taking my ham
let smells like cheese looking for a
nice thick blob look like you're about
to go fencing on God our cheese has set
for another 15 minutes that already
looks better oh it's a Farnam curd when
we add the hot water to initially heat
up the curd we're gonna let that water
come to room temperature I throw in some
salt look at that geez oh my god it
feels like freshly shampooed hair let's
blast it and then we're gonna start
making our bowls oh wow this is cheese
lava
they say that you don't use a gloves
there is no way in awesome that you can
make much so the gloves
only the real cheese only the real art
gets formed when you do it like this oh
yeah
[Laughter]
do you see that so next we're gonna make
a little saltwater brine so we're gonna
add some of our drained way which will
be the liquid that our finished
mozzarella balls will go into so that
they can be seasoned
oh please be good I can't tell if it's
still rubbery maybe more stretching
still need a salt like inside we're
gonna make another match what we're
adjusting this time is we're gonna go
down to one drop of rennet because too
much run it can result in a rubbery
cheese yogurt it didn't occurred only
thing we changed was the Rena haha
alright well that didn't work so here we
go two drops around it in our first few
attempts we at least got to a gelatinous
curd after five minutes so after five
minutes we should check okay it's been
five minutes we're gonna take a look
we're doing something wrong it's liquid
it's completely liquid let's give it
five more minutes in another five
minutes
yeah we're that's not cheese what the
did we do everything has been exactly
the same I don't know why this is the
problem with raw milk last time we did
five minutes it was with the pasteurized
milk not the raw milk we're gonna put
this pot on hold in case it thickens up
when we just each make our own badges
done may the best cheese ball wedding I
will make a batch of cheese with the
pasteurized milk
Nicky's gonna make another attempt with
the last raw milk gallon we have and
either cheese is gonna happen today or
we're just gonna have lots of pots of
milk I'm adding my rennet one two you're
going three drops yeah my citric acid
nice and dissolved alright so it's been
about thirty minutes on this guy
it's definitely curdled oh yeah it's
good yeah it's working it just needed
more time what we thought was our failed
fifth attempt has been sitting for
another 15 minutes and it's actually
working I'm gonna keep making that this
worked five minutes doesn't work with
raw milk that's a nice looking curd
though this looks really similar to the
video it's like super grainy and crumbly
it's a lot of salt in here I'm a little
worried
this isn't coming together like the
first one did not enough salt too much
salt
oh god is that when I give it I'm not
giving up on this why that is the only
thing we changed can you get water out
of here and get more honor in here
something's happening something's
happening so Jesus is it really yeah eat
that it's cheese okay I think we should
go more boiling water Oh mother pearl I
think we should just try to form it into
a big ball yeah one big ball oh sweet
baby Jesus keep it in the water keep the
temperature high I think I should ball
it up now you know it's really hot do
you want me to get the cold water to
pull your hands maybe do you mean Hannah
yeah okay I'm good okay it's pretty good
here we go
[Music]
I'm good I think done this yeah put it
in the water we never gave love you know
alright it's time to cut into that last
extremely hot and painful fall of
mozzarella oh is it
Wow it's really soft Wow
cheese it's like creamy inside no it's
perfect
yes the texture is amazing it's like
almost the liquid yeah
[Music]
yeah this is our victory it's a symphony
on your mouth we're making little pizza
dough's from the dough that we made for
pizza Oh should we put a slice to garlic
oh yeah okay so focaccia I think we
should go cheese olive oil and salt
let's make it yeah got some basil we
eventually got to a cheese that I think
closely resembles that in the video
didn't really help at all yeah well just
a little bit she made all of this stuff
so we've got at recruiter eboard
with Sciuto your parmesan from your
cheese wheel some crackers two types of
salami
we have folk cocktails okay season
finale let's all eat some cheese this is
so good we had lovely mozzarella and
then we finally had what we found out
yellow looks like the season has been
many stressful days of trial and error
all the foods that are made in those
viral food videos are made by people who
are like masters of their craft and so
it's just been really fun to try and
like replicate their process
and see how they do things got a little
bit of a behind the students taste and
make it for ourselves you can't fail
every time this has been eating your
theme
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]